Two graphics cards. One is 5 years old
and has 12 GB of memory. The other is
newer, has 16 GB, and costs 60% more. On
the same model, the same test, the same
settings, the old cheap one writes text
faster, 42 tokens a second against 34.
The newer card has more computing power.
It just has less memory bandwidth, 288
GB a second against 360. That is the
whole trick. When a model writes you a
sentence, it is barely doing arithmetic.
It is reading. And reading is bounded by
memory. Five things decide whether local
AI works on your machine. Four of them
are not printed on the box you have been
comparing. How fast your memory is. How
many bytes get read per token. Whether
the thing fits. How much context you ask
for. And what you are actually running
it for. Get those right and a $250 card
beats a $4,000 one at your job. Get them
wrong and you spend two grand to run
something worse than a free API. So,
number one, memory bandwidth. And why
the number on every spec sheet turns out
to be the wrong one. Here is what
generation physically is. To produce one
token, the machine reads every weight in
the model out of memory and does a
single pass. Then it throws that away
and does it again for the next token.
So, the ceiling is arithmetic you can do
in your head. Tokens per second is
roughly your memory bandwidth divided by
the bytes you read per token. Real
engines land between half and three
quarters of that. An 8 billion parameter
model at 4-bit is about 5 GB. On that
old card, 360 divided by 5 is 72.
Measured, it does 55, 77% of the
ceiling. Run the same model up the
ladder and the line stays straight. A
3090,
936 GB a second, 115 tokens. A 5090,
1792,
200 tokens. Now, take the card away
entirely. Dual channel desktop memory
runs about 96 GB a second. 18 times less
than the top card. And that shows up as
roughly 11 tokens a second on a 7
billion model. Apple sidesteps the whole
argument by putting one pool of fast
memory behind everything. An M5 Max
moves 614 GB a second across 128 GB of
it, which is how a Mac Studio ran a 671
billion parameter Deep Seek at around 17
tokens a second. Pulling under 200 West,
no rack, no cooling problem, no cloud.
But bandwidth only governs half the
work. Reading your prompt is a different
job. That part happens in parallel, so
it is bound by compute. Watch what that
does to our two cards. At prompt
processing, the newer, weaker card wins.
1,480
tokens a second against 1,119.
Same two cards, opposite answer. Paste
huge prompts and you want compute. Chat
and you want bandwidth, which brings us
to the second thing. And to the number
people quote most, parameter count. On
its own, it tells you close to nothing
about speed. One graphics card, a 3090.
Qwen 3 at 32 billion parameters, dense,
35 tokens a second. Qwen 3 at 30 billion
parameters, mixture of experts, 153.
Four and a half times faster on a model
that is very slightly smaller. Because a
mixture of experts model does not read
all of itself. A router wakes a handful
of expert blocks per token, and the rest
stays asleep. Alibaba ships 35 billion
total with 3 billion awake. Google ships
26 billion with 3.8 awake, and says on
the model card that it runs about as
fast as a 4 billion model. The catch is
that sleeping weights still take up
room. That 35 billion model is 20 GB on
your card, whether the experts fire or
not. Sparsity buys you speed. It does
not buy you space. You can see the
ceiling that creates. Moonshot open
source Kimmy K3 recently. 2.8 trillion
parameters, 1.4 terabytes of weights,
6,800 likes on hugging face, 2,850
downloads. The parameter count is real.
Nobody is running it. Third thing, and
the one that cost people the most money,
does it fit? Miss the size of your card
by 1 GB and you fall off a cliff.
Someone benchmarked it properly on a 14
billion model. Everything on the
processor, 2.9 tokens a second.
Everything on the graphics card, 43. 15
times. Now the interesting part, push 40
of the 48 layers onto the card and you
get 12 and 1/2. 83% of the model on the
GPU buys you 29% of the speed. The last
eight layers do the rest, which is why
everybody quantizes. Full precision
weights are 16 bits each. Quantizing
rounds them down to four or five bits in
small blocks with a scale factor kept
per block so the range survives. A 32
billion parameter model goes from 65 and
1/2 GB to under 20. That is the
difference between renting a data center
GPU and using a second-hand card in the
machine you already own. The cost is
usually described as a 1 to 3% quality
loss, which is a generous way to put it.
Measured against full precision on the
same prompt, 4-bit picks a different
next word 8% of the time. Down the
ladder, 8-bit is effectively free, 6-bit
is cheap, 4-bit is the knee, 3-bit does
real damage. 1-bit turns a perplexity of
six into a perplexity of 60. It is still
talking. It has stopped thinking. The
damage is not spread evenly either.
Dropping to 3-bit cost one model nine
points on grade school maths and 6/10 of
a point on common sense. Quantization
eats reasoning first, and reasoning is
usually why you came. Google trains for
it now. Their quantization-aware
checkpoints cut the 4-bit penalty by
more than half and took a 27 billion
model from 54 GB to 14. The community
rule, pick a file 1 to 2 GB under your
VRAM, and that rule is about to fail you
because the model file is not the thing
that fills your card. Fourth thing,
context, which is bigger than your model
and which almost nobody accounts for
before they download anything. Every
token the model has already read leaves
something behind. A key and a value per
attention layer cached so it never has
to recompute them. That cache sits in
your VRAM next to the weights and grows
with every word. On an 8 billion model,
it costs about 147 KB per token. At
4,000 tokens of context, that is 6/10 of
a gigabyte, small enough to ignore. At
128,000 tokens, the same cache is 19 GB.
The model file is five. Your context is
now nearly four times bigger than your
model. So, the calculator you used
before you downloaded anything was
wrong. Weights plus cache plus a working
buffer plus whatever your desktop
already has sitting on the card. People
shrink the cache the same way they
shrink the weights, but this is where
the tutorials go wrong because keys and
values are not equally fragile. Quantize
the values to four bits and the
divergence from full precision is nearly
nothing. Quantize the keys to four bits
and the model now agrees with its own
full precision answers only 11% of the
time. The reason is mechanical. Keys
pass through a softmax, so an error at
one position spreads across every
position. Values just get added up, so
their error stays put. 8-bit keys, 4-bit
values, and you keep 60% of the memory.
Architecture fixes better than settings
do. DeepSeek compresses the cache to 70
KB a token instead of 300. Gemma
alternates local and global attention
and drops the cache from 60% of
inference memory down to 15% and now the
part that should change what you buy.
Somebody pushed 172 billion tokens
through 35 open models at 32,000,
128,000,
and 200,000 tokens of context. Median
accuracy loss from 32 to 128,000 tokens,
10 and 1/2 points. One well-liked model
fell from 93% to 37% at 200,000. Its
invented answer rate went from 7% to
72%.
Same study, same machines. 8-bit weights
cost under two points. Context costs 20.
The setting everyone argues about barely
matters. The number in the marketing is
the one that does.
And the one that decides whether you
should do any of this at all. What are
you running it for? Start by not
agonizing over the app. For one person
making one request at a time, Llama.cpp,
a Llama, and LM Studio land within a few
tokens a second of each other. vLLM is
much faster at serving 40 people at
once, which you are not doing. Two
things did change this year. In
February, the team behind llama.cpp
joined Hugging Face. Georgi Gerganov
wrote that local inference is becoming a
competitive alternative to the cloud,
and the way people deploy it has to get
simpler. In March, a Llama swapped
Llama.cpp for Apple's MLX on Mac. Same
machine, same model. Prompt processing
up 57%, generation up 93%.
A bigger jump than any card you could
have bought that month. The chip
underneath barely touches quality.
Across an H200, an MI300X,
and a Gaudi 2, accuracy on the same task
varies by half a point. Temperature
moved it up to nine times more than the
hardware did. Then there is the bill.
Open AI will sell you a million input
tokens for 5 cents. Deep Seek will run a
capable model for 14. Meanwhile,
American electricity hit 18 and 1/2
cents a kilowatt hour, up 6% in a year,
and the card got worse, not better. The
5090 carries a $2,000 sticker and sells
for about $4,300
because the memory makers moved their
lines to data center parts. The break
even people keep landing on under $50 a
month of API spend, Cloud wins outright.
Above a few hundred a month sustained,
the machine pays for itself inside half
a year. The capability gap is real, too.
On the standard software engineering
benchmark, the best closed model scores
89. The best open weights model scores
79, and that one wants a server, not a
laptop. Agents are where you feel it
most. Past roughly 25 to 30 tool calls,
local models lose the thread. They
forget early results, redo finished
steps with a context window still half
empty. So, here is the yes. Local wins
at small, repetitive, private, and
constant. Classification, extraction,
summarizing your own files, auto
complete, anything you would rather not
paste into someone else's server. And it
is not a hobby anymore. Llama reports
8.9 million monthly developers, double
January, running inside 85% of the
Fortune 500 on a team of 14 people. Open
weights took 41% of Hugging Face
downloads this spring. On Vercel, open
models handle close to a third of all AI
requests in June, and the gap has a
measurement now. The UK AI Security
Institute put open weights 4 to 7 months
behind the closed frontier, narrowed
from 6 to 10 months a year ago.
Practically, 8 GB runs a 9 billion model
at 4-bit with real context. 16 runs a 12
billion or a 26 billion sparse one. 24
runs a 27 billion coding model at 25
tokens a second on a laptop. Five
things: bandwidth over compute, bytes
awake over parameters, fit with that
cliff behind it, context, which is
bigger than your model, and the job,
which decides all four. Buy bandwidth,
count what is awake, leave room for the
cache, and be straight with yourself
about the work. That is the checklist.
Everything else is a preference.